et entre deux sont nous sommes en direct
avec notre reporter n'a déjà des razak
nadège vous êtes place du palais royal
c'est gilet jaune espère interpeller le
pouvoir et protester donc contre les
interdictions de manifester ce qu'ils
sont nombreux au rendez vous
écoutez je peux pas vous dire s'ils sont
nombreux au rendez vous en tout cas ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que il y a
plusieurs têtes en plusieurs têtes
connues du mouvement des gilet jaune
jérôme rodriguez eric drew et qui a été
contrôlé par la police un peu plus tôt
verbaliser 235 euros damende pour
manifestation a une pour participation à
une manifestation interdite depuis on
voit derrière nous il ya quelques
minutes
maxime nicole a été également contrôlé
par les forces de l'ordre il est un peu
plus loin derrière nous donc défilé je
ne vous l'avais dit eh bien qu'ils
veulent à nouveau investir les être au
coeur des institutions politiques la
manifestation est prévue a été prévu en
tout cas son départ d'ici quelques
minutes manifestations qu'on n'arrive
pas à voir visuellement puisque les
manifestants ne se sont pas ne sont pas
visibles à l'oeil nu un puisqu'il ne
portent pas leur gilet jeunes je les dis
pour éviter d'être verbalisé l'on voit
la manifestation qui doit démarrer d'ici
quelques minutes et qui doit rejoindre
plusieurs lieux de pouvoir vous l'avez
dit le sénat à l'assemblée nationale le
ministère de l'intérieur et puis
l'elysée en fin de journée ça va être
compliqué hein pour ces manifestants
d'attendre l elysée puisque le
dispositif de sécurité extrêmement
important on a plusieurs
plusieurs centaines de deux membres des
forces de l'ordre autour de cette place
de cette zone du conseil d'état et puis
on va peut-être rejoindre à eric drew et
que l'on voit eric drew et c'est une
figure du mouvement des gis les jeunes
qui a annoncé il ya quelques quelques
jours s'être retiré du mouvement il a
été contrôlé ce il ya une heure à peu
près il a été verbalisé de 135 euros
pour participation à une manifestation
interdite
alors eric drew et racontez moi comment
ça s'est passé vous êtes arrivé tout à
l'heure et vous avez été verbalisé pour
quelle raison on m'a même pas précisées
au final que c'est un contrôle
d'identité de base et j'ai vu qu'ils
prenaient leur téléphone pour mettre une
amende comme ils font d'habitude on va
même pas précisé que j'allais d'amendé
au club ce soit c'est globalement pour
une manifestation interdite
on n'était que deux personnes on arrive
en premier ont cherché à boire un café
on s'est fait remonter et vous aviez dit
il ya quelques quelques jours vous avez
dit que vous ne faites faisait plus
partie du mouvement des gilet jaune
pourtant vous êtes là alors que vous
savez que et bien une manifestation a
été déclarée ce qu'essaye de faire des
manifestations déclarées se retrouvent
plus loin la ona s'est parlée par les
forces de l'ordre nous c'est dans un
autre contexte ici on a décidé de faire
un peu ce qu'on voulait et de manifester
notre propre façon de spontanément comme
ça c'est un droit constitutionnel mais
apparemment ça plaît pas à tout le monde
donc vous êtes toujours gilet jaune ou
pas on peut pas on peut pas dire qu'on
est plus gilet jaune on sera toujours
chez les jeunes quoi qu'il arrive c'est
un état d'esprit donc c'est quoi c'est
quoi le programme de la journée là vous
les l'objectif c'est de rejoindre
l'elysée en fin de journée ça va être
possible
là pour l'instant on est les journées
juste en train de se balader entre amis
et après à 15 heures il y aura un
on a un autre lieu de rendez-vous on
pourra tous ceux se rencontrer il est au
rendez vous ça veut dire que coco c'est
une manifestation sauvage que vous
prévoyez non on est en groupe d'amis là
ça fait ça fait presque un an et demi
qu'on marche ensemble donc on avait
décidé de se retrouve aujourd'hui ouais
merci à eric drew et pour ces
informations vous l'avez entendu eric
drew et bien qui dit venir se balader
ici dans cette zone de manifestation
déclarée et des forces de l'ordre bien
qu'ils continuent de procéder à de
nombreuses interpellations de nombreux
contrôles de police